[Music]
for this aspect of the apprehension of
the object that is as it exists in the
shape of Consciousness we have only to
recall the earlier shapes of
Consciousness already encountered thus
in regard to the object so far as it is
an immediacy that is is an indifferent
being we saw observing reasons seeking
and finding itself in this indifferent
thing that is we saw it equally
conscious of its action being external
to it as it was conscious of the object
only as an immediate object
and we saw observing reason at its peak
express its specific character in the
infinite judgment that the being of the
eye is a thing and moreover a sensuous
immediate thing
when the eye is called Soul it is true
that it all it is also represented as a
thing but it's something invisible
intangible Etc and therefore in fact not
as an immediate being and not as what is
meant by a thing that judgment taken
just as it stands is non-spiritual or
rather is the non-spiritual itself
in its notion however it is in fact the
most richly spiritual and this inner
significance of what is not yet apparent
is what is expressed in the two other
moments to be considered
paragraph 790 is continuing on with the
looking back into hegel's phenomenology
and retracing or at least to use the
term here recalling Erin remembering the
steps that have been taken so far and
you notice that at the end of this
paragraph We have this reference to two
other moments to be considered and this
is going to happen in paragraph 791 and
paragraph
792 and you know if we look ahead a
little bit in 793 these are going to be
called the reconciliation of spirit with
itself and so Hegel is not just
summarizing here he is trying to say
look what we did back then what we what
we observed what we went along with is
phenomenologists this term turns out to
have been more than just what we were
seeing at that time this is leading us
to the point of being able to grasp
absolute knowing or you might say rather
to be
absolute knowing to participate in it
together with each other
so he begins this paragraph by talking
about this aspect of the apprehension of
the object there are fossans you know
gripping onto grasping the object the
gegenstein the thing that stands over
against us which is going to turn out to
be for us and we're going to have a bit
of ourselves in it and so he he goes on
here and he tells us
as it exists in the shape of
Consciousness so you know the entire
phenomenology has been tracing out the
history of the development of
Consciousness which gets quite
complicated and involves you know uh
consciousness of a particular moment
reacting against its limitations or
other consciousnesses or what has been
on the scene already and then moving
ahead dialectically developing and so
the way that we're going to do this is
through this process as he says of
recalling
the earlier shapes of Consciousness the
gestalten this before signs already
encountered and you know that's all of
them in here right because we're at the
final stage of Consciousness we have
traced out a number of different shapes
so what is the one that he's going to
focus on this time so notice in the
previous paragraph 789 right we were
talking about
earlier shapes of Consciousness and we
went through this this knowing in terms
of uh spiritual essentiality and a whole
bunch of other shapes and what did we
get into what did we remember what did
we bring up out of the depths well it
was primarily stuff from the
Consciousness section now we're going
into reason the big reason section
and specifically observing reason the
old boxes rather
um
and you know we saw that a lot of that
had to do with this kind of scientific
attitude towards the world and we saw
Hegel talking about all sorts of
interesting science of his time and then
we get to probably the most interesting
portion of that section where it's no
longer just the object out in the world
that we're observing whether it's in
terms of like acids and bases and
properties and all that kind of stuff
forces laws or in terms of observing
animals
and there are various you know functions
like reproduction irritability and all
that now we're actually going back to
and recalling the observation of the
human being as an object
of study and what does that mean well
that means the phrenology and
physiognomy section where we're looking
at people and saying aha we understand
what's going on because we understand
the way your skull or your other
arrangements of matter have have been
arranged have come to be come to be
developing out of uh what you are right
and we can look in the mirror and do
that as well you know oh I got a nice
skull there you know I must be one of
those brainy types or you know oh look
at that that's not so good so we go on
and he says
in regard to the object insofar as it is
an immediacy right uh
it is an indifferent being now this is
kind of an interesting phrasing here Ein
gleich gulti design so being a b enzyme
right a thing
because like gold diggers
um could be indifferent but it could
also be that it's indifferent because
whatever we take it up as it's just as
good that's another way of translating
you know figurative sense like good
figures right it has some value but it's
the same value no matter what and what
is it that's checking this out observing
reason
and finding findin itself
in this indifferent thing
so it's not just that observing reason
is
looking at studying investigating this
object as immediacy this indifferent
being whatever it happens to be
it's finding itself
in there and it's not just
coincidentally finding itself in there
it is seeking
itself seeking what of itself well
perhaps the desire to to know
the desire to understand
and here he brings up two additional
aspects of this so we've got this
movement towards the object and then we
also have uh he says consciousness
of the object only as immediate object
so this is the way Consciousness is
actually grasping it
but it's also conscious of its action
being external to it now it's action
it's
comportment
being external to it being external to
the object being external to its own
self the indifference we could say
Creeps in to the action and what action
are we talking about here the action
that's required to make sense of this
this thing that's confronting it the
object in front of it
now here's where we get to the real
interesting meat
we saw observing reason at its peak at
its Spitzer right at the the height
express its specific character right
um or specified character but in the and
here he talks about an infinite
judgmental right the infinite judgment
that what
that the being
of the eye
is a thing
now the being of the eye that is
observing reason
observing about itself it is the eye
it's not looking at you know
toads and rock formations and finding an
eye there you find the I as the Observer
looking at your own thought processes
and uh you know here we have the
reduction of the I to as he says a
sensuous immediate thing
and you know what are we talking about
here
um well you know spirit is a bone as we
said so long ago so he goes on and he
says something interesting here now when
the I is a soul then we TR we go beyond
we transgress the boundaries of we
transcend seemingly although perhaps
transgress is a better term
um
the thing can no longer as he says be
something sensuous and immediate it is
now something invisible you can't
actually see the soul intangible
Etc so you know all the other sort of
aspects so he says therefore in fact not
as an immediate being and not what is
meant as things so we've got two
different sides to the human subject
that takes in the objects in the form of
observing reason it is on the one hand
of sensuous thing it can look at itself
in the mirror and say aha that's me
right there or he looked out at itself
or you know watch a video of itself
whatever that may happen to be and on
the other hand it is also soul
but it's not sold by being soul is
separate from the body it's the aspect
of the body that is not simply reducible
to object is immediacy not just a
sensuous immediate thing but is
the I now both of these have to be kept
in view so he says that judgment and so
the Judgment has two sides right the
judgment
uh taken just as it stands is
non-spiritual or is the non-spiritual
itself now it's non-spiritual
non-geistiga right not being of spirits
so reason in this case can kind of lose
its way and on the other hand
insofar as we're trying to think you
know of something more than just the
immediate thing he says
in its notion it is in fact the most
richly
spiritual
so which is it well it's both at the
same time and he says this inner
significance of what is not yet apparent
here we get to the where we began is
what is expressed in the other two
moments to be considered and it will be
expressed by working through these other
two moments
the thing is I in point of fact in this
infinite judgment the thing is
superseded in itself it is nothing it
has meaning only in the relation only
through the eye and its connection with
it
this moment manifested itself for
Consciousness and pure insight and
Enlightenment things are simply useful
and to be considered only from the
standpoint of utility the cultivated
self-consciousness which has traversed
the world of self-alienated spirit has
through itself alienation produced the
thing as its own self therefore it still
retains its own self in it and knows
that the thing lacks self subsistence
that it is essentially only a being for
an other or to give complete expression
to the relationship that is to what
alone constitutes the nature of the
object here the thing counts for it as
something that exists on its own account
it declares sin certainty to be absolute
truth but this being for itself is
itself declared to be a a moment that
merely vanishes and passes over into its
opposite into a being that is at the
disposal of an other
paragraph
791 as we're carrying out this task of
looking at a remembering previous shapes
of Consciousness drawn from the
phenomenology we see that there's a lot
of telescoping and jumping over vast
sections that is taking place here
because what is this section referring
to earlier we saw Consciousness and
reason coming up now we're like right in
the heart of spirit actually getting
closer in some respects to the and
certainly beyond the midpoint of it and
interestingly if you look at the
previous paragraph right where this
infinite judgment when enlika's urtile
was brought up now we actually have a
reversal of the terms and it's kind of
funny that you know Hegel seems to think
nobody's actually going to notice this
somebody who pays so much attention in
other places to The Logical form of
propositions so he tells us the thing is
I what we had before was the I or the
being of the eye is a thing now we have
the the thing is I
and he's going to say that this is going
to be well at least the thing itself is
going to be superseded alcohol but very
important term that we've seen many many
times in the phenomenology it's the way
the dialectic proceeds so the thing is I
in point of fact in this infinite
judgment the thing is superseded so the
Judgment isn't superseded the
proposition isn't superseded one term of
it in this case the subject is being
superseded how so he says well in itself
on Zeke
it's nothing
it is a nothing there's nothing there
and we could jump ahead to the end of
this uh passage where he's going to
reinvoke sense certainty you know uh the
thing counts for it for something else
as something that exists on its own
account it declares sense certainty to
be absolute truth it sounds like we're
back at the beginning but notice what he
says there but this being herself is
declared to be a moment that merely
vanishes and passes over into its
opposite into a being that is at the
disposal of another so if the thing
isn't nothing it's got a nothingness
within it it only has
value we could say in relation to
something that is not merely a thing the
I in this case and so Hegel will talk
here about he'll use several different
interesting terms right meaning
um
so you know the meaning
of the nothing that is the thing the
relation
you know in a relation to the I and what
does he what has he got to say there it
has meaning only in this relation only
through
the I
and its connection
with it
whose connection well we could interpret
this two ways the thing has a connection
and a relation and a meaning for the I
and the I also has
connection to itself meaning within
itself through the thing
right so what is this going to lead us
to he tells us this moment manifested
itself for Consciousness now manifested
is kind of a
kind of ambitious term here hot Zeke air
Gaben right it it offered itself it gave
itself it manifested as fine uh for
Consciousness
in now here we get to some shapes of
Consciousness from the spirit section
right in pure insight and remember what
was Insight being raised in relation to
there were a couple interesting
dialectics with dualities in the spirit
section first we had you know all the
whole thing about law and two different
kinds law of the city a lot of the Gods
the law of the family then we moved on
to you know cool Dynamics like wealth
and state power and how those work out
the noble and base Consciousness and
then finally we get to Faith and then
what conquers faith
or at least that to some degree Insight
anzith right
so
um Ryan and einsticht is pure insight
and then we get to the enlightenment the
auf Clara right Hegel thinks that the
enlightenment is massively important
historically but also for the
development of Consciousness as spirit
so that's what's going on here and
there's lots of things going on in the
enlightenment but the aspect that Hegel
is going to pick out here
has to do with usefulness he says
things are simply useful right and are
nuts league and are to be considered
only from the standpoint of utility of
their usefulness for us so I mean what
does this mean well things don't have
value in and of themselves they have
value in their relationship to living
human subjects who can say I who can
make use of the thing usefulness right
there right who can take advantage of
the thing who can give a meaning give an
assessment to the thing the thing can't
give an assessment to itself and we are
in a thoroughly humanized World here at
this point and he talks about world
right so he talks about the cultivated
self-consciousness that has uh traversed
and again we see this word Duke involved
there Duke Loaf and right to travel
through the world the wealth of
self-alienated uh zupps and families
becoming alien to itself becoming
um foreign to itself other to itself
spirit and it becomes through this
process of traversing this world of
self-alienated spirit which is a world
of other human beings
a world of human meanings a world of
things that have their usefulness for
other human beings we could think about
this although Hegel doesn't talk here at
this point as something
intergenerational is something
inter-subjective right you become an
alienated
self-consciousness by leaving a world of
things that seem to have value in
themselves behind and entering into a
world of spirit where everything has a
price and its price is what somebody is
willing to pay for it based upon its
usefulness in relation to them in
relation to their desires in relation to
what it is that they intend to do you
can swap things in relation to each
other things become replaceable become
reducible to others so this is all
involved in the self-alienation here and
it tells us this cultivated
self-consciousness has through itself
alienation now there's several different
things he says has produced or zoys
right brought brought about the thing as
its own self
and he says that there is a knowledge a
knowing Vice there it it knows
what does it know something about the
thing and the other thing that or the
other moment that we have to talk about
that here is it retains its own self in
it so
in grasping the thing as something that
has been imbued with meaning with value
through relationship through connection
to the subject
suddenly
the subject has placed itself
in the thing that's one reason why the
thing has the usefulness or value that
it does that's one reason why we can
talk about it as not just having
usefulness or value for this
self-consciousness but for other
self-consciousnesses as well if
something merely has value only for you
in a certain way it's not a thing it's
not a part of a economy it's not part of
a society of self-alienated spirits
self-consciousnesses all right so we can
go on from here he says that
it knows the thing what the the thing
is useful but the thing also lacks
self-subsistence it lacks a independence
of itself why because as he says it is
essentially only a being for another so
the thing insofar as it is considered in
itself
is really nothing it's only in insofarad
as it is for another that it has any
sort of genuine being and we should
remember too that usefulness is about as
low as you can go in the scale of of
value and being right it doesn't have
self-subsistence in what matters it does
have self-subsistence in you know
existing or in lasting so for example
you know a piece of chalk this
cylindrical thing right here if I put it
away and you know leave it in my desk
drawer somebody can come back long after
I'm dead and be like Oh I'm assuming
they're still using chalk in the distant
future Ah that's a piece of chalk or
they could be like what is this object
oh this was a thing that people back in
the day used to use to write on these
these Boards of slate that we called
chalkboards and they came and print out
things properly from our vantage point
in the future right and it has meaning
only insofar as it is a humanized
artifact it can have existence it can
have mere being all you want
nobody cares it only matters insofar as
it is something for other human beings
and like I mentioned maybe we stop using
chalk and this
because it doesn't have self-subsistence
and only exists in relation to those of
us who actually understand its usage its
usefulness
suddenly no longer has the meaning that
it previously
enjoyed it's taken away right so he says
and here we come to the end of this
passage
or to give a complete expression to the
relationship to what alone constitutes
the nature of the object here the thing
counts for it is something that exists
on its own account it declares send
certainty be absolute truth the thing
insofar as it can actually
metaphorically declare anything is
telling us what you see is what you get
this is the reality
but we see already that that is nothing
and it breaks down in its meaning and
its reference in its relation to what it
is for another for us as
self-consciousnesses and so you know
this is what Hegel takes to be an
important essential moment uh in the
development of spirit in a self uh world
of self-alienated spirit in which we
self-consciousnesses are also
self-alienated which means that uh we
ourselves although he's not saying it
here are things that exist in relation
to others as well